dans notre série le hasard fait parfois
bien les choses nathalie sarraute et
précisément notre invité ce soir
présence extrêmement flatteuse quart à
91 ans on peut dire son âge
cet écrivain n'a jamais beaucoup
encombraient la télévision et les
journaux télévisés c'est le moins que
l'on puisse dire
la comédie française vient d'inaugurer
sa nouvelle salle du vieux colombier à
paris avec deux pièces de nathalie
sarraute
elle est là et le silence pour résumer
très schématiquement face au silence
d'un homme dans un groupe d'amis les
autres personnages sans nom vont essayer
par la parole de le faire sortir
précisément de son silence petit extrait
parlons d'autre chose
voulez-vous ctv dit qu il ne sait pas
quel diable c je suis ridicule quand je
me laisse emporter par ses élans ce
lyrisme qui me prend parfois studio
c'est enfantin
je sais plus ce que je pensais
c'était très ému c'était si non je vous
en supplie nathalie sarraute bonsoir
réellement flatter content très heureux
de vous accueillir sur les ondes de
france 2 elle vous même est ce que vous
êtes flatté d'être à l'honneur pour la
réouverture de cette deuxième salle de
la comédie française
enfin un flat et n'est pas le moment
vraiment ça me touche beaucoup et j'ai
beaucoup apprécié et aimé autrefois le
vieux colombier et qu'on inaugure
maintenant le vieux colombier avec deux
pièces de moi ça m'émeut ça me touche et
ça me fait pas en même temps une sorte
de responsabilité
précisément vous avez toujours été
présente à la lecture de vos pieds c'est
ce que vous avez noté une évolution de
la perception de vos textes
au fil du temps ça a été un changement
un grand changement et je dois dire je
beaucoup beaucoup aimé la mise en scène
j'aime beaucoup les mises en scène de la
salle en général est peut-être très
content de la façon dont il est mis en
scène ces deux pièces mais c'est une
manifestation de sa personnalité puisque
c'est lui qui fait tout le travail de
metteur en scène comme le faisait claude
régy qui manifestait une personnalité
différente
c'était un point de vue qui était tout à
fait différent mais qui était aussi
expression de tous la vision du metteur
en scène pop le metteur en scène joue un
grand rôle dans les pièces puisque
moi-même je n'imagine jamais comment
elles seront mises en scène le péril sa
route sans vous faire rougir on peut
dire que vous avez signé l'une des
oeuvres les plus importantes de la
littérature contemporaine des pièces de
théâtre on vient d'en parler très
rapidement des essais mais aussi dix
romans déjà publiés et un onzième est en
préparation c'est cela sur quel thème on
sait pas un roman ce sont des textes
brefs mais qui sont pas terminées je
suis en train d'écrire je ne sais pas
combien
ça va durer combien de temps je vais
encore écrire ce sont des textes brefs
un peu comme dans l'usagé de la parole
mais centré dans une autour d'un même
thème
est ce que vous écrivez toujours dans un
café un bar pmu avec des libanais ou
autres futurs besoins en fèves de la
foule pour écrire j'ai besoin d'abord
d'être hors de chez moi
et puis d'avoir un bruit extérieur et
apaisant quelle agréable et se trouve
que c'est un café on vous retire ses il
n'y a pas mal le libanais qui parle
arabe
mais même s'il parlait français ça ne le
dérangerait pas alors qui chie à la
maison thomas dérange on a vu on a vu
tout à l'heure sur portage pour le
premier concours du roman une chose
peuvent peut-être rassuré les écrivains
en herbe vous même vous avez beaucoup de
difficulté à me faire éditer pour
certains de vos romans pendant que
tropisme a été refusée pendant plus de
deux ans et ça c'est finalement très
rassurant pour tous ceux qui débute une
carrière littéraire
henry je crois que c'est difficile
d'avoir plus dessiner plus de refus que
comme moi d'abord fort tropisme pendant
deux ans puis pour portrait d'un inconnu
déjà préfacé par ça impossible de
trouver un éditeur
et quand enfin on en a trouvé un et bien
elle a vendu au prix du papier les qu'il
a vendu 400 exemplaires
il a vendu grâce aux prix papier l.sane
a été réédité que des années après vous
êtes vous le dites il vous êtes une
droguée de lecture depuis le plus jeune
âge n'ont pas su poser simplement cette
question quels conseils pourriez vous
donner aux jeunes qui hélas au jeune
français qui hélas lisent de moins en
moins pour découvrir cet amour des
livres
ça c'est très difficile à dire mais pour
ce qui est d'écrire si j'avais un
conseil à donner c'est de n'écouter
aucun conseil de cdc allait à ce qu'ils
entendent y de faire eux-mêmes et pour
lire pour pour découvrir le la joie
d'ouvrir un livre qui faisait des choses
très difficiles me semble apprendre à
quelqu'un comme d'apprendre à écouter la
musique on aime on n'aime pas je crois
que on aime la lecture depuis son plus
jeune âge on aime écouter de la musique
on aime regarde
la peinture donc on peut les uc et quand
on l'a déjà mais quand on a pas ce goût
ça me paraît très difficile a éveillé
mais enfin on essaie puisque open hack a
écrit un livre pour montrer comment ils
arrivent en faire aimer la lecture
absolument merci infiniment nathalie
sarraute d'avoir été notre invité je le
répète votre présence sur les ondes de
télévision sont extrêmement rares et je
rappelle à tous nos téléspectateurs que
l'on sente de votre oeuvre sera très
très bientôt publiés à la pléiade
merci encore une fois infiniment